tu n'es pas le sel qui meurt où elle
s'attache tu frottes ta joue à toutes
les moustaches faut se lever de bon
matin pour voir un ingénu qui ne t'ai
pas connu
trs libre à n'importe qui dans ta ronde
cœur d'artichaud tu donnes une feuille à
tout le monde jamais de mémoire d'homme
moulin n'avait été autant fréquenté le
pierre à Paul en passant par Jul et
Félicien embrasse-les tous embrasse-les
tous dieu reconnaîtra le sien passe-les
tous par tes armes passe-les tous par
tes charmes jusqu'à ce que l'un de les
bras en croix tourne de l'œil dans tes
bras les grands op petits en allant
jusqu'au lilip pucien embrasse-les tous
embrasse-les tous dieu reconnaîtra le
sien jusqu'à ce qu'amour s'en suivre
qu'à son cœur une PL vire le plus touché
d'entre nous demande grâce à
genoux en attendant le baiser qui fera
mouche le baiser qu'on garde pour la
bonne bouche en attendant de trouver
parmi tous ces galant le vrai mère le
blanc en attendant que le petit bonheur
ne t'apporte celui derrière qui tu
condamneras ta porte en marquant dessus
fermé jusqu'à la fin des jours pour
cause d'amour de pierre à Paul en
passant par julet Félicien
embrasse-les tous embrasse-les tous dieu
reconnaîtra le sien passe-les tous par
tes armes passe-les tous par tes charmes
jusqu'à ce que l'un de les bras en
croire tourne de l'œil dans tes bras des
grands
optis un allant jusqu'au lilpuien
embrasse-les tous embrasse-les tous
reconnaîtra le sien alors toutes tes
fredenes guillelous et prê en trin tes
écarts tes grands écarts te seront
pardonnés car les filles quand ça dit je
t'aime c'est comme un second baptême ça
leur donne un cœur tout neuf commment
sortir le sang
[Musique]
neuf